What we can do next is
to multiply both sides of these equations on
both sides by U dagger, meaning the conjugate transpose of U.
And if we do that, we get the two equations
that you see right here.
We're using the fact that U dagger times U is the identity matrix.
So that's why we don't see U or U dagger on the left hand side of either equation.
And now we can consider the inner product between Psi and Phi.
It's the same as the inner
product of Psi and Phi multiplied to the inner
product of the L zero state with itself
because the inner product of
any state with itself is one and that includes the L zero state.
And now if we look at our two equations, we see that this expression here is equal to the inner product of the vectors
represented by the two equations. And in particular it's the inner product between the left hand
sides of these equations.
So we can equally well
express this inner product as the inner product of the vectors represented by the right hand
sides of these equations,
because the left hand side is
equal to the right hand side for both equations.
So we get this expression right here, which is the inner product
of the two right hand sides of the equations or equivalently,
it's the conjugate transpose of the first multiplied to the second.
U times U dagger is equal
to the identity matrix, because U is unitary and so it goes away.
And we can simplify just a little bit to get the product of
these inner products.
Now remember that we don't know anything about the relationship
between Pi zero and Pi one, so we don't know what
their inner product is.
That's a mystery to us. But whatever it is, we're multiplying it to the inner product of Ket 0 and Ket one, which is zero.
So the end result is that
we obtain the value zero, but that's what we wanted to show, the inner product between
Psi and Phi is equal to zero.
So the two states are orthogonal.
So don't bother trying
to perfectly discriminate two non-orthogonal quantum
states, you just can't do it.
There is a converse to the
statement that we just proved, which is that orthogonal quantum states always can be perfectly discriminated,
and this is not too hard to
see if we make use of a fact that I mentioned earlier in the lesson.
Specifically if Psi and
Phi are orthogonal states, then one thing that we can do is to choose any unitary matrix U
whose first two columns
are the two states.
We know that it's always
possible to do this and it doesn't matter
for the sake of this task exactly how this unitary matrix is chosen.
All that's important is that these are the first two columns.
We don't need any additional Qubits. If we simply apply U to
the two possible states, then we'll get these
two possible outcomes.
And if we measure the top most Qubit, which remember is the right most Qubit, then we'll get a zero or a one
depending on which state we started with.
Alternatively, we can consider
a projective measurement with outcomes zero to one
defined as you see right here.
in this case, the measurement
actually only depends on Psi.
This measurement perfectly
discriminates Psi from any state that's orthogonal to Psi.
If we measure Psi with respect to this projective measurement, then we'll get the outcome
zero with probability one as these equations review.
And for any state Phi
that's orthogonal to Psi, we'll get the outcome
one with probability one.
I won't go through the
details of these calculations, but if you're interested, I encourage you to go through
the details on your own.
And that is the end of lesson three. We covered a lot of
material in this lesson, including quantum circuits,
inner products and orthonormality, projections and projective measurements, the fact that global phases don't matter,
the no-cloning theorem, and the fact that non-orthogonal states can't be perfectly discriminated while orthogonal states can.
I hope you'll join me for
the fourth lesson soon, which is the last lesson in
the first unit of the series.
In the fourth lesson, we'll talk about three
very important examples, teleportation, superdense coding,
and the CHSH inequality or CHSH game as it's sometimes described.
Goodbye until then,